marine le pen la présidente du front
national est l'invité de preuves par 3
public sénat afp dailymotion bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous et avec guillaume
daudin de l' agence france-presse et
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
tout à l'heure la situation économique
et sociale servent aux ambitions
électorales marine le pen pour les
prochains scrutins l'élection municipale
d'abord ou d'ailleurs pour la première
fois on vous donne gagnants et gagnantes
heures puisque vous êtes sur la liste à
hénin beaumont
et puis également le scrutin européen
bien sûr qui permet on le sait à chaque
fois aux électeurs d'envoyer un message
de colère
si un tiers des français disent
aujourd'hui adhérer à vos idées selon le
dernier baromètre tns sofres on constate
quand même qu'une large majorité reste
style à certaines de vos propositions
phares comme par exemple la sortie de
l'euro mais nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure françois hollande s'investit on
le voit à fond aujourd'hui dans son
nouveau positionnement que vous allez
pouvoir juger positionnement pro
entreprise pro capitaux pro et
investisseurs étrangers le jour même où
peugeot citroën ouvre son capital aux
chinois dongfeng est ce que vous êtes
inquiet de cela et rassuré par ailleurs
de la décision de l'état français
d'entrer à la même hauteur dans le
capital 14% ont de toute façon peut
jamais se réjouir quand une industrie
française est obligé de faire appel à
des capitaux étrangers
ça veut dire que cette entreprise va mal
cette industrie va mal et nous le savons
et elle va mal parce que l'euro est trop
fort et que donc elle n'arrive plus à
être compétitives à cause du taux de
change et c'est la faute de la famille
peugeot des erreurs de stratégie et une
en jaune est objectivement je ne le
pense pas je pense que si l'euro était
moins chère l'industrie française s'en
sortir est beaucoup mieux et donc
l'industrie automobile aussi alors qu'il
entrait dans le capital
des chinois est une chose si ça reste à
14% bon on peut éventuellement
considérer que c'est supportable -
combien ça serait un support dès que dès
que le poids est plus trop important et
que par conséquent je peux pas vous dire
parce que ça dépend de combien détenus
le capital est détenu et par qui voilà
il peut y avoir des accords dans une
entreprise avec des dt temps des
détenteurs de capitaux qui se mettent
ensemble pour pouvoir défendre une
politique est contraire à celle de
l'intérêt de la france bon mois le
danger pourquoi je suis inquiète parce
que je sais très bien que les chinois à
différence des français d'ailleurs
le gouvernement chinois ne pense qu'à
son intérêt et cas l'intérêt de son
industrie à lui or il est en train de
développer une politique industrielle en
matière automobile de développement des
marques chinoises et donc je peux
éventuellement m'inquiéter que cette
décision n'en prennent pas un transfert
délocalisations des centres de décision
et d'innovation vers la chine
parce que évidemment là on y perdrait de
notre substance et et on serait appauvri
inquiète et en même temps rassuré je
vous le disais par la décision du
gouvernement d'entrer dans le capital et
on entend arnaud montebourg qui utilise
le mot patriotisme ça peut vous plaire à
ceux du patriotisme
oh mais c'est bien sûr que ça peut me
plaire tout à fait ça peut me plaire il
ya 15 ou s'il ya oui ou non mais je
soutiens la démarche jusqu'au bout c'est
la démarche pense que l'état doit
prendre ses responsabilités pour une
grande entreprise française telle que
celle là qui est une grande entreprise
dans un secteur hautement stratégique et
surtout gros pourvoyeur d'emplois le
seul problème si vous voulez c'est que
le patriotisme il pleut il s'arrête là
pour une raison simple c'est qu'on ne
peut pas mettre en oeuvre une priorité
nationale
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas mettre en
oeuvre à une classe sociale ou bien par
les a sauvé l'entreprise met d'accord
mais par exemple un conseil régional qui
veut totalement changé son parc de
voitures
eh bien il n'a pas la possibilité
d'acheter les voitures françaises il
n'en a pas le droit parce que l'union
européenne interdit elle est là la
limite à la politique de monsieur
montebourg de la même manière quand
nicolas sarkozy à son époque la fmm
cinéma que monsieur montebourg et avait
expliqué que l'état allait venir en aide
aux sous-traitants automobiles français
eh bien ils avaient juste omis de dire
que l'union européenne s'y opposerait et
d'ailleurs
opposés et par conséquent on n'a pas pu
venir en aide à ce secteur qui est un
secteur essentiel
alors françois hollande le patriote
parce qu'elle se présente aussi comme ça
on l'a entendu lors de sa conférence de
presse a critiqué en vantant où vous
l'avez vu l'attractivité française une
conception étriquée de notre intérêt
national ceux qui ont peur de s'ouvrir
au monde at il dit ceux qui ne veulent
ceux qui veulent se protéger c'est vous
oui mais parle que de moi de façon à
chaque fois sa conférence de presse il
ya un petit un petit pique contre une
petite pique contre le front national
c'est l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille
des pigeons maintenant françois hollande
les choses sont claires je veux dire il
a pris la décision d'aller déroulé le
tapis rouge devant les grandes
multinationales et si possible les
grandes multinationales étrangères
c'est son choix ce n'est pas de nous
parce que figurez vous mais ces
investissements qui viennent de
l'extérieur créés dans des emplois oui
très bien non il crée pas d'emplois
c'est d'ancrer d'elle en place sont les
tpe les pme et pmi dans l'assolement et
ce sont celles là qui sont flinguer
consciencieusement alors je vais vous
donner par exemple deux éléments dont
personne n'a parlé ils ont pris une
décision monsieur ayrault en
l'occurrence pour requalifier les
apprentis en salariés vous savez quelles
conséquences ça va avoir pour les tpe ça
veut dire que toutes les entreprises qui
étaient au niveau de neuf salariés vont
passer avec cette qualification au delà
c'est à dire à des entreprises de 10
salariés avec toutes les conséquences de
seuil qui vont leur tomber dessus
ils ont supprimé le crédit d'impôt
apprentissage et il met en oeuvre un
pacte de responsabilité qui en réalité
je les démontrer à d'ailleurs à monsieur
moscovici ne pourra pas être utilisée
par les pme et les pmi pour une raison
simple c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas
fournir la contreparties en termes
d'emploi
parce que pour une entreprise de neuf
salariés pourquoi je prends ça parce que
c'est l'immense majorité des entreprises
françaises neuf salariés et moins
et bien c'est à ce crédit d'impôt ce
sera dix mille euros de cadeaux qui leur
est fait sauf qu'en contrepartie on leur
demandera une dépense qui représente une
embauche c'est à dire vingt mille euros
donc c'est toujours la politique qui est
faite pour les gros
pour ceux qui en réalité n'ont pas
besoin de l'aide de l'état c'est un même
politique que celle qui a été menée par
nicolas sarkozy
et on n'a pas répondu à la question la
grande question comment va-t-on financer
cela augmentation de la csg
comment va-t-on le financer par une
nouvelle cure d'austérité mais j'imagine
qu'on aura ces informations après les
européennes à la volonté de réduire les
dépenses mais ça dépend quelle dépense
s'il s'agit de défendre et le système de
protection sociale s'il s'agit de renier
sur les indemnisations des chômeurs
c'est ce qui a été fait on l'a vu en
grèce en italie au portugal avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît et qu'on
ne nous dise pas que ça va mieux puisque
le troisième plan grec est déjà en
préparation dead de sauvetage de l'euro
sauf que là encore madame merkel fait la
même politique que françois hollande
elle dit on en parlera après les
européennes parce qu'il faut bien que
les français ne connaissent pas la
vérité pour pouvoir envisager de voter
encore pour les socialistes pour l'ump
je reviens sur les très grandes
entreprises internationales marine le
pen donc devant lesquels on déroule le
tapis rouge
on connaît votre opposition à la libre
circulation des personnes vous êtes
également contre la libre circulation
des capitaux pour être précis sur ce
point là un poids de près si je pense
qu'il faut avoir un contrôle on peut
parfaitement envisager d'avoir contre
eux ce serait d'ailleurs un bon moyen
objectivement de lutter contre la fraude
fiscale parce que les mêmes notamment
l'extrême gauche qui ne cessent de râler
contre la fraude fiscale ils sont pour
l'ouverture totale des frontières alors
faut savoir ce qu'on veut
parce que si on n'ouvre totalement les
frontières alors on n'a pas défendu
qatar ou du koweit qui était représenté
à la lie à l'elysée lundi vous n'en
voulez pas je peux vous dire que les
fonds du qatar et de l'arabie saoudite
moi je serai à la tête de l'état jeu
ferai en sorte de ne pas livrer notre
économie à ces deux pays pour une raison
simple et une raisons éminemment
politique c'est que j'accuse ces pays
très clairement d'être les soutiens et
les financiers du terrorisme
international et du fondamentalisme
islamique partout voilà et congés payés
qui était représenté à l'elysée lundi
précise et voilà ces pays
ces pays qui sont des esclavagistes
puisqu'on a appris que je crois il ya
400 450 indiens qui sont morts sur les
chantiers de la future coupe du monde je
crois au qatar mais tout ça en ferme les
yeux nous grand donneur de leçons de
morale à la terre entière grand
défenseur des droits de l'homme quand il
s'agit du kata en laye a plus personne
perd tout le monde ferme les yeux se
bouche les oreilles et ne voit pas ce
qu'est réellement ce pays pour des
raisons d'argent se fait acheter en
quelque sorte
non ils achètent notre silence et bien
moi en l'occurrence je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux
est ce que vous estimez qu'à moins de 20
% de bonnes opinions aujourd'hui
françois hollande joue son va tout avec
le pacte de responsabilité que auquel
vous croyez pas apparemment non je n'y
crois pas je n'y crois pas il joue son
mais il n'y a pas un domaine de sa
politique je crois qui est susceptible
demain d'entraîner l'adhésion des
français et les résultats ne seront pas
au rendez vous voilà c'était une chose
absolument clair il n'y aura pas d'
inversion de la courbe du chômage depuis
des signes encourageants quand même hein
on a une croissance un peu plus soutenue
que prévu non mais cui un rebond de
consommation regard des investissements
passeraient de 0 3% de croissance 0,2
peut-être que ce soit mais très
honnêtement mais il ya des signes
positifs a eu aucun la note de dette a
atteint 2000 milliards ce don là encore
personne ne parle
le chômage est atteint des records 5
millions officiellement probablement
plus plus près de 7 millions 80 % des
cdd des emplois à des embauches l'année
dernière on était décédé danser mais là
je vous parle des chômeurs en trois ans
77 % de baisse des investissements
étrangers l'année dernière justement
c'est contre ça qu'on essaie de vente et
l'attractivité des sites industriels oui
sauf qu'ils se trompent
le problème c'est qu'il ne fait pas le
bon constat donc temps qu'il fera pas le
bon constat il donnera pas les bons
médicaments donc le bon constat c
2 d'admettre que l'euro est beaucoup
trop cher que les pme/pmi attendent
toujours la promesse de françois
hollande de liesse progressif et il ne
l'a pas mise en oeuvre les sociétés par
conséquent cet impôt sur les sociétés
les pme pmi la paye plein pot quand les
grandes entreprises du cac 40 on le sait
ne paye elle que 8 % etc etc alors
c'était un certains évoquent un
remaniement peut-être même avant les
municipales et le nom de claude
bartolone revient à lui qui avait
critiqué l'europe de l'austérité comme
vous il ya un instant est ce que vous le
préféreriez jean marc ayrault
mais je crois que ça ne changera
strictement rien je crois que les
français doivent prendre conscience que
la première chose à faire c'est de
libérer notre pays du carcan européen
construit cette prison qui a été
construite et par l'ump le ps et dans
lequel ils ont verrouillé le peuple ford
est d'accord pour une partie de nos
cités seront ils sont d'accord pour
essayer de déverrouiller demander
comment ils sont d'accord et ils sont
d'accord pour critiquer l'union
européenne pendant la campagne mais en
l'occurrence quand ils sont à strasbourg
ils continuent à voter toutes les
directives qui continuent à fermer un
triple tour la prison dans lequel ils
ont enfermé l'europe en parlant d'âge en
pension je ne suis pas dupe des effets
de manche préélectoraux ce que je vois
c'est l'effet et les faits c'est qu'ils
veulent plus d'europe plus de 2
d'intégration comme ils disent
européenne
françois hollande s'est rendu ce mardi
matin la grande mosquée de paris
est-ce qu'il se devait selon vous
d'inaugurer ce mémorial du soldat
musulman
on connaît tous un l'apport déterminant
des soldats musulmans durant les guerres
française
excusez moi je n'ai pas cette vision
communautariste et moi ces dix jours je
trouve que cette manière de diviser les
français entre musulmans chrétiens juifs
ça me fait vomir voilà car moi je crois
à l'unité de la france et ses soldats
qui sont remarquables et qui méritait
cette mosquée qu'on leur a offert est
d'accord mais ils étaient français voilà
et nous leur devons comme un tous les
soldats français
la reconnaissance du pays mais venir
faire du communautarisme et donc qu'on
ne se raconte pas d'histoires de
l'électoralisme
avec ces soldats morts je trouve ça mais
vrai
man critiquable plus haut point voilà
alors ils ont notre reconnaissance comme
on notre reconnaissance tous les soldats
français qui sont morts pour défendre
notre pays
mais arriver à les diviser jusque dans
la mort j'avoue que je trouve ça
terrifiant et ça répond d'ailleurs on le
sait très bien ça répond à quoi ça
répond exclusivement à une manipulation
politicienne
parce que monsieur hollande a reçu des
sondages sur son bureau qui lui disent
que les français musulmans qui ont voté
beaucoup pour lui
s'abstiendrait donc il est inquiet donc
ils lancent des signaux mai mais tout ça
c'est pas de regret c'est peut-être à
l'ump qui essaye justement de séduire
cet électorat cap et de troubler par
certaines réformes de société sur la
famille vous vous passez pas cette
concurrence alors l'électorat musulman
pas digne moi je m'adresse à tous les
français je ne les détermine pas en
fonction de la couleur de leur peau
je ne détermine pas en fonction de leur
religion ça c'est la politique de
l'apartheid et c'est cela oui de
l'apartheid oui de l'apartheid
ce qui consiste à séparer les hommages
les politiques en fonction de la couleur
de la peau de la religion ça s'appelle
l'apartheid alors alors c'est de
l'apartheid doux mais c'est de l'appart
est quand même et le ps se rend là
coupable d'une grande violation des
règles et des valeurs de la république
dise la marine le pen alors que françois
hollande a décidé de lancer l'armée
française en centrafrique pour essayer
justement de réconcilier les communautés
religieuses ethniques avec toutes les
exactions qu'on a connue la france va
envoyer des renforts supplémentaires est
ce que vous estimez que la démarche est
la bonne là deux façons ne peut pas
faire autrement cher monsieur d'accord à
partir du moment où on a décidé d'y
aller
eh bien nous arrivons là bas ils nous
nous rendons compte qu'il faudrait le
rôle de la france a été positif on a
évité pour ce stade
à ce stade le génocide il faut c'est
violent sebring milliers de soldats
supplémentaires
et je crois que l'union européenne nous
en a proposé 500 dans l'union européenne
ferait mieux d'ailleurs comme je les dis
allah au parlement européen de nous
aider financièrement pour supporter
cette intervention plutôt que de nous
envoyer quelques soldats européens quand
jamais mis les pieds en afrique de toute
leur existence qui n'y connaissent
d'entre vous le regretter mais vous ne
condamnez pearn amassé deux mentions
maintenant ça n'est pas ce que je dois
je ne dis pas on est bien seul je le
regrette je dis que plutôt que l'union
européenne nous envoie 500 soldats qui
n'ont jamais vu de leur vie un pays
africain et non jamais a fortiori
combattu sur ces territoires qui sont
difficiles qui nous laisse le faire on
connaît bien cela mais qui nous aident
financièrement pour qu'on ne supporte
pas l'intégralité de la charge
financière de cette intervention
allaient aurait évoqué maintenant les
municipales donc avec ce sondage sur
hénin beaumont qui vous donnent gagnante
combien de villes visées vous
précisément
même s'il dit on vous connaissez des
difficultés à monter votre bolide
partout on en parle avec guillaume
daudin de l' agence france-presse
d'abord le reportage de camilla campus
anneaux qui a justement suivi manuel
valls dans le pas-de-calais dans sa
tournée anti front national financé par
les contribuables sous les feux des
projecteurs à lens manuel valls vient
officiellement installé nouvelles zones
de sécurité prioritaire un déplacement
qui prend vite des airs de campagne
électorale
lance un choix stratégique ici marine le
pen a décroché la deuxième place aux
présidentielles de 2012
avec plus de 26 % des voix je vais pas
des campagnes anti je fais des campagnes
pour la république pour les valeurs et
pour la sécurité de nos concitoyens
donc le résumé mon action à cela sort
est à côté de la plaque
aucune ambiguïté pour le ministre de
l'intérieur dans son entourage on
murmure tout de même le mot de tournée
anti fn trois semaines après nimbe
hautmont il rencontre les lensois
au programme visite des commerçants un
petit mot avant de repartir prendre une
pause café dans cette boulangerie son
opération communication ne passe pas
inaperçu tu es pas on a lancé raid et
main à des gens
potentiellement de sombres de son bord
que ça va faire changer d'avis ceux qui
n'y sont pas quoi
absent des élections municipales de 2008
le front national semble devenir un
concurrent de taille
le candidat fn de lens se sent même pris
pour cible par le ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est clairement un déplacement en
thiéfaine à un mois quelques des
élections c'est une évidence
on peut se poser la question à savoir si
on peut on va pas saisir la commission
nationale des comptes de campagne comme
l'a fait monsieur briois nabot le
candidat bleu marine reçoit jean marie
le pen le 1er mars
visiblement ps et fn n'hésite pas à
envoyer leur artillerie lourde pour la
conquête de l'hôtel de ville de lens
voilà game de navettes avec nous de
notre confrère de l'agencé presse qu'on
salue puisque c'est votre première
participation à preuve parfois que votre
vos questions à marine le pen
bonsoir marine le pen vous avez dénoncé
à plusieurs reprises une tournée anti fn
de manuel valls est d'ailleurs steeve
briois votre candidat à hénin beaumont a
même annoncé qu'il allait saisir la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut faire baisser le score du fn aux
élections municipales
non je crois qu'ils les faits remontent
à d'ailleurs fait dans les sondages le
démontrent sur hénin beaumont dans le
s'est passé le français est donné
gagnant
voilà c'est que je compte inviter à
venir vous voir partout à l'eau mais je
les utilise et de gagner il suffit de
suivre le manuel valls à la trace il ya
quel malheur c'est que c'est pas son job
quoi il est payé pour ça
ah il touche je crois un salaire de la
république ce ministre là il se déplace
avec beaucoup de personnels de sécurité
tout ça est payé par les contribuables
est ce que les contribuables sont
obligés de payer les tournées anti front
national de monsieur valls il le fait
parce que ça il est là bas aussi pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe sur le plan
sécuritaire le précise voyons un
engouement ah bon et a une âme au mans
est allé voir quoi monsieur alors dans
ces cas là tu as écouté il est allé
visiter rien du tout mais les chances de
sécurité
pas vraiment mais a voté à hénin moment
il est allé aux voeux du maire qui avait
des yeux comme ça et qu'il n'avait
d'ailleurs pas invité
donc il s'est invité à baulmes ans donc
je dis que quand on a les résultats
aussi pitoyable que ceux de manuel valls
en matière de lutte contre l'insécurité
en matière d'augmentation de la présence
clandestine dans notre pays
eh bien on se fait son job et on n'est
pas agent électoral des pauvres
candidats ps de 6 ou de la municipale
les sandra les sondages sont un peu
contrasté donc il ya un moment où les
vous annonce gagnant il ya des bonnes
villes par exemple 37% à brignoles 35% à
béziers qui a des villes comme paris ou
vos listes ne ferait que 8 % à bordeaux
c'est 6% strasbourg 7 % est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya un petit
tassement dans les sondages ces derniers
temps non mais j'ai vous aimeriez bien
j'ai je lis vos tweets régulièrement et
je vois que ça vous ferait plaisir
maintenant je ne le crois pas voilà par
conséquent je pense que tout va bien et
que dans les villes que vous citez
notamment paris on était à 3 donc si on
passe la barre des 10 comme je le crois
ce sera une multiplication assez
spectaculaire du score tu m'aimes je
connais pas beaucoup de partis
politiques qui d'une élection à l'autre
et capables soit capable d'apporter une
si forte augmentation de ces scores
alors bien sûr il ya des villes plus ou
moins bonne pour le front national pour
une raison simple c'est qu'il ya des
villes qui ont une ancienneté
d'implantation locale plus ou moins
importante la progression du fn dans les
sondages et même électoralement personne
ne la conteste par contre par exemple en
novembre le fn était annoncé à 22%
d'intentions de vote - municipal ce mois
ci c'est 15%
c'est inquiétant quand même monsieur
dame parce que vous êtes censé être un
spécialiste de la politique vous savez
bien pourquoi il ya une telle différence
il faut lui répondre je vais leur
envoyer les questions je vais lui
répondre je n'ai pas posé de question
j'ai 17 à 14
quoi sera fait
mais parce que mois de novembre vous
interroger les gens vous interrogez 100%
des villes sauf que au mois de novembre
les électeurs français ne savent pas
dans quelle ville il y aura un candidat
front national
à partir du moment où vous arrivez au
mois de janvier eh bien les ans les gens
savent demande vraiment s'il souhaite
voter pour le bien sûr monsieur d'hommes
et faut pas prendre les français pour
des idiots vous savez si les français
savent que dans leur vie il n'y a pas de
candidat front national ils vont pas
vous dire je vais voter front national
au municipal jusqu'à pas de candidat
front national dans leur ville donc en
réalité c'est ça qui explique cette
baisse nous sommes présents nous serons
présents dans à peu près la moitié des
villes de plus de 10 mille habitants
dans l'autre moitié c'est comme si on
faisait zéro en quelque sorte donc nos
électeurs qui n'ont pas le choix de
voter pour un candidat front national
bien soit ils s'abstiennent soit ils
reportent leur vote sur un autre
candidat ce qui est tout à fait normal
au fn plusieurs personnes parlent de
cinq à dix villes gagnable aux
municipales est ce que ça vous paraît
une fourchette ou des mois je donne pas
de fourchette je ne donne pas de
fourchette nous verrons bien mais moi je
pense que nous sommes capables de gagner
des villes lesquels c'est absolument
impossible de le savoir personne ne le
sait d'ailleurs car avec la règle de la
triangulaire et des quadrangulaires il
est impossible de faire une projection
donc il y a et je dorme merci de me
permettre de de préciser ce qui est
apparu dans certains médias faussement
il y à quinzaine de villes dans lequel
nous avons le potentiel pour gagner
voilà nous sommes à un niveau électoral
qui nous permet d'être dans la marge où
l'on peut gagner une ville j'espère que
dans ceux ckrs ville potentiellement
gagnable nous en gagnerons le plus
possible
est ce que vous espérez dans combien de
villes passé des accords locaux avec
l'ump par exemple non je ne l'espère pas
ça n'est pas notre politique
vous avez fait une proposition non c'est
le protocole qui est sur la table pour
les candidats c'est je pense que c'est
réglé
il y aura peut-être quelques cas entre
les deux tours elle nous les analyserons
si on nous en fait la demande si
effectivement des candidats
signe la charte du rassemblement bleu
marine car nous ne faisons pas d'accord
politiciens nous faisons des accords si
c'est ça la politique c'est normal non
pas faire des accords avec des gens qui
ne sont en désaccord avec les dix points
qui nous apparaissent incontournables de
notre âge anticipe à lire et à vous en
faites assez ça exactement mais mais bon
voilà pour l'instant donc y aura
peut-être quelques cas mais la règle
générale c'est que nous serons présents
au second tour pour gagner des villes
bien sûr mais aussi pour avoir le plus
de consistance
vous avez quand même donner un chiffre
vous estimez que vous avez une quinzaine
de villes quand tu es niable l'habitant
une potentiel électoral nous permet
d'être un niveau où sa ville sont
gagnables dire dans vous avez dit à
perpignan lors votre meeting ce samedi
vous ne demanderait aucun maire élus
d'aller au delà de ces compétences
municipales
pourtant plusieurs de vos candidats
soutiennent des mesures de préférence
locale par un clou et aliot à perpignan
il a parlé de réserver les marchés
publics aux entreprises du département
qui souffre de concurrence déloyale
il a aussi parlé de choisir des
entreprises qui embauchent de la main
d'oeuvre locale
est ce que mr peu près mettre en place
ce genre de disposition
eh oui monsieur dowd a tout à fait non
c'est parfaitement légal
et si vous venez dans le nord pas de
calais ou cancer régional vous
apercevrez que le groupe front national
a déposé cinq ou six motions et veut
visant justement à modifier les critères
d'attribution car vous le savez dans un
marché public
il y à des critères et on accorde un
pourcentage à chaque critère or dans ces
critères il y en a deux qui nous
apparaissent très intéressant et qui
peuvent permettre de donner un privilège
aux entreprises locales c'est le lin
duel de crucell le critère écologique
est notamment considéré que l'empreinte
carbone d'une entreprise qui arrive avec
des camions d'europe de l'est
eh bien ça fait baisser en quelque sorte
son attractivité dans le choix du marché
public et donc plus une entreprise est
proche et moins plus ce critère est
positif pour lui et puis aussi critère
social s'est autorisé par l'union
européenne
c'est tout petit un certain
donc oui enfin tout ça c'est pour
détourner quand même les situe la
stupidité des interdictions qui sont
imposées par l'union européenne et
entreprises qui embauchent de la main
d'oeuvre locale c'est possible et alors
il est alors donc je vous dise dans ce
critère social vous vous apercevrez
qu'il y à deux éléments très
intéressants
le la non suppression d'emplois et les
embauches éventuelles et donc ces deux
critères la mis ensemble permettent de
donner un petit avantage à nos
entreprises nationales et en
l'occurrence aux entreprises locales par
rapport aux entreprises étrangères
parler de réserver les marchés publics
aux entreprises du département
réserver ses positions ça veut dire que
des entreprises en démarrage
mais je crois qu'avec ces deux critères
avec avec la mise en oeuvre de ces deux
critères dans une immense majorité de
cas on peut permettre aux entreprises
qui sont de la région de pouvoir être
mieux placé que des entreprises qui
seraient des entreprises étrangères donc
c'est tout à fait légal et vous avez un
candidat à périgueux qui sur son site
internet propose la plupart regardent
les joies de ses programmes
je vois si propose l'application de la
préférence nationale pour l'attribution
des logements sociaux
est-ce que c'est faisable aussi non ça
n'est pas faisable devra lui dire alors
ouais il faudra lui dire mais
heureusement que monsieur dowd island et
la cellule riposte au front national 6 à
l'ump ou au ps mais avec beaucoup
d'attention la soirée il le démontre ce
soit avec nous dit au public lancé par
jean-françois copé sur j'ai beaucoup de
choses à faire en matière de logement
parce que c'est vous vous intéressez au
programme municipal
il ya notamment exigé quand on est maire
que
l'on respecte la manière dont on utilise
les locaux car bien souvent les
logements sociaux sont accordées à des
gens qui n'ont aucun respect pour ce
logement qui ne l'utilisent pas en
respectant le cahier des charges
donc là le maire peut exiger que le
cahier des charges de l'eau d'une
occupation paisible sereine soirée saint
jean je pense à bord je pense à des gens
qui ne respectent pas mal de bruit après
vingt-deux crise du nord qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que le nombre qui
pour lequel le logement est accordée etc
etc ou sont des choses qui arrivent oh
oui ça arrive ça arrive je joue le comte
terme bon et puis et puis je pense
également que il y aura très
probablement moyens et j'engagerai le
débat juridique sur ce point de respect
réserver une partie des logements
sociaux aux personnes âgées car je crois
que les personnes âgées sont en très
grandes difficultés financières qu'elle
ne et qu'elles ne font pas l'objet d'un
traitement à part elle devrait faire
l'objet sur le terrain j'ai traitement à
part plusieurs de vos candidats propose
de réserver les logements sociaux ou les
aides de leur municipalité aux habitants
de leur ville est ce que c'est un petit
peu anormal non mais elle par rapport
aux étrangers en disant ça sera ça sera
que nos habitants et pas les étrangers
est ce que c'est possible
non ça n'est pas possible ça en l'état
de la loi ça n'est pas possible nous
mener ce que 12 bateaux même de faire
campagne sur eux
avec ces propositions alors c'est vrai
c'est vrai que moi je vais vous dire
partout où je vais je vois des candidats
socialistes qui font campagne en vendant
une gare tgv qui évidemment ne verra
jamais lieu
je vois beaucoup de choses j'entends
beaucoup de choses dans une dans des
campagnes municipales proposent non bien
sûr moi c'est pas un mensonge
je crois que ils ont le désir d'accorder
un privilège aux habitants de leur ville
c'est vous qui dites que c'est pas pour
aux étrangers est ce que ces marques et
aux habitants de leur ville plus si m
il me semble que c'est l'un de vos
secrétaire départemental plus besoin
doivent être aidés avant des étrangers
le prince charmant mais après ce
monsieur dowd un sas est une c'est une
déclaration de politique générale que
auquel j'adhère bien sûr il me paraît
normal que les habitants de la ville
soit quand même
et quand même une priorité par rapport
aux étrangers je vous donne un exemple
éclairant par exemple parlons-en
lorsque des roms s'installent installe
un camp illégal dans une ville et que le
préfet arrive en exigeant que la
municipalité logent les roms clandestins
avant les habitants de la ville vous
trouvez ça normal
et bien moi je trouve ça profondément
scandaleux et donc je suis parfaitement
d'accord pour envisager les moyens de
pouvoir pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
réfléchir juridiquement a une ancienneté
dans la ville pourquoi est ce que ceux
qui sont installés dans ça ne se fait
pas au niveau local mais en amont
monsieur sur le logement quand même bon
pourquoi ne pas envisager la possibilité
juridique par exemple de tenir compte de
l'ancienneté de l'ancienneté
d'installation dans la ville pour
pouvoir
comment accorder les logements sociaux
tout ça ça se discute on peut très bien
envisager cette possibilité alors qu'il
reste une minute pour vos guides j'avais
un d'alors le jean françois copé a
relancé une polémique sur les sur les
livres qu'ils s'attaquaient aux
stéréotypes sexuels et il ya certains de
vos candidats qui demande le retrait de
ses livres par exemple votre candidat à
toulon demande dans la bibliothèque de
tout le monde le retrait d'un certain
nombre de livres
quelle est votre position sur le sujet
je suis contre le retrait de tout livre
de toute bibliothèque
je suis pour l'introduction d'un certain
nombre de livres plutôt que leurs 13
entre lesquels vous n'importe tous ceux
qui n'y sont pas ceux de nant voilà par
exemple ceux notamment qui n'ont
peut-être pas l'heur de plaire mais je
vais vous avez une grande conversation
là dessus
de monsieur zemmour par exemple même
s'ils devraient ou non vous êtes un très
bon enquêteur monsieur mandat de la
fille vous ayez aller dans les
bibliothèques de france pour vérifier
j'en suis quand même passé on l'a
forcément c'était des doutes avec melzer
de livres voilà donc des gens comme ça
qui expose une pensée qui ne plaît pas
au pouvoir voilà je pense que il faut
qu'ils aient tous les livres car moi je
crois à l'intelligence des français
je crois que les français doivent
pouvoir avoir tous les livres entre les
mains et se faire eux mêmes une opinion
ça n'est pas aux municipalités de
choisir quel livre on lit ou pas quant à
ces livres là qui sont destinés à des
enfants de 4 ans je crois bon il me
semble que les parents sont là pour
mettre entre les mains de leurs enfants
les livres que les parents considèrent
comme don pour leurs enfants mais ont
quand même assez rare de voir un petit
gamin de 4 ans je vais aller tout seul
pour aller choisir ses livres dans la
bibliothèque met donc merci guillaume
quand votre sens de la rigueur
merci d'avoir été avec nous avons une
honte pour vous mais une enquête sur lui
c'est pas possible
reda on aimerait quand même bien avoir
la liste des livres que vous avez envie
de faire entrer dans les bibliothèques
merial faudra nous la donnait marine le
pen des livres digue de renaud camus de
zemmour il ya des vaisseaux et locales
mais vous dis oui vous accompagne
beaucoup d'ailleurs alors dites moi vous
auriez un mot sur manuel valls là vous
l'avez critiquer tout à l'heure on
l'avait voulu vous voyez un destin
national destin non pas particulièrement
non non je crois que monsieur valls
bénéficier en réalité d'un effet miroir
d'une là bénéficié d'ailleurs s'est
terminée d'une popularité en effet
miroir avec madame taubira
voilà mais je pense qu'il a beaucoup
d'ambition oui mission héros et de
monsieur hollande am stram gram pic et
pic et colégram briguera-t-il c'est un
autre sujet vous avez dit dans perrine
tarneaud arrive juste avant ce détour
par l'oise où vous êtes présente
d'ailleurs ce mardi soir et où aurélia
mousli rencontrer des électeurs qui sont
prêts apparemment à se détourner des
partis traditionnels de droite comme de
gauche
une démarche d'ailleurs qui semble
autant politique que sociologique dans
certaines communes le front national a
bien du mal à boucler ses listes
mais ici à formerie commune de 2000
habitants dans l'oise
le maire sortant aura bien face à lui
une liste rassemblement bleu marine une
politisation que l'élu sans étiquette de
la bourgade ne comprends pas je pense
que la liste qui est en face de moi
manque beaucoup d'expérience puisqu'il
n'ya aucun ancien élu ou très peu qu'ils
ont tenue des jeux d'hier et des villes
importantes ou moyenne et donc il ne
faut pas de connaissance suffisante de
la commune on rentre dans la politique
politicienne dont quelques années c'est
évident dans le canton voisin à
grandvilliers la candidate frontiste a
totalisé 54 % des suffrages à la
législative partielle de l'année
dernière ici pas de liste fn aux
municipales pourtant la population
locale voit dans le front national un
remède à tous les maux
moi je pense que là les élections ça va
encore contester cette parti socialiste
ils vont prendre quelques outils là
puisque les gens en ont marre des gens
en ont peut-être marre de la droite
marc da gauche sont tellement été déçus
tellement été arrangés qui veulent
changer les hommes politiques nous
abandonne alors que au front national il
reste ce sont des gens qui sont nés dans
la dans le coin qui vivent avec nous qui
travaillent avec nous je sais ce sont
ces gens là qui sont là exaspération
sentiment d'abandon des thématiques que
stéphane rosa se connaît bien
pour le politologue l'isolément des
populations et l'arrivée de nouveaux
habitants venus de la ville favorise le
vote frontiste dans des zones
d'isolement géographique social
territorial le vote front national
apparaît comme un substitut politique
cette année dans l'oise une dizaine de
liste rassemblement bleu marine devrait
se lancer dans la bataille des
municipales en 2001 dans ce même
département
le fn avait pu boucler que de liste pour
la perrine tarneaud est avec nous au
péril vos questions à marine le pen
on va parler des municipales jusqu'aux
européennes les européennes vous avez
trois élus actuellement bruno gollnisch
votre père et vous même vous viser une
fourchette entre 15 à 20 euros députés
en 2014
et est-ce que visé est ce que vous visez
pour vous le rôle de leader d'un futur
groupe parlementaire souverainistes à
rosso sont pas des choses qui se décide
à l'avance en règle générale d'abord on
construit un groupe c'est déjà le plus
important est la question est là dans la
construction la question de la
présidence d'un groupe arrive après que
ce groupe ait été construit moi je pense
que nous aurons un groupe et c'est ça je
crois les animaux avec des gens avec
lesquels nous sommes en contact régulier
nous nous apprécions nous travaillons
ensemble depuis de nombreuses années
pour certains le fp autrichien qui est
très bien positionné pour les élections
européennes
je l'espère le pvv de geert wilders qui
est donnée en tête aux pays bas les
démocrates suédois avec laquelle nous
travaillons depuis longtemps y en a qui
ne veulent pas de vous comme les anglais
do you keep oui enfin les anglais ils
sont en grève ça fait un des leurs et
ils veulent garder cela surtout il
pourrait vous empêcher de faire le vôtre
alors ils pouvaient pendant que je
retrouve trop extrémiste maintenant
parce que non parce que les contacts que
nous avons sont des contacts qui ne
viennent pas du groupe du zouk mais
c'est vrai que l'équipe aimerait
conserver la présidence de son groupe et
avoir son groupe à lui mais on ne sait
jamais faut pas insulter l'avenir s'il
n'y arrive pas rien ne dit que des
rapprochements pour le tracé plus court
un peu trop extrême
oui c'est le meilleur moyen de se dé
diaboliser un leader c'est le meilleur
moyen se dédiaboliser soi même vu qu'ils
sont victimes comme nous d'ailleurs
d'attac qui sont extrêmement brutales
comme à chaque fois que vous allez à
l'encontre du système
à chaque fois les méthodes sont les
mêmes vous savez il est pas con france
pour être tout à fait honnête
à chaque fois on vous traite de fasciste
de raciste d'ailleurs ça manque beaucoup
d'imagination
photo ap tout essayé de renouveler un
petit peu plus radicalisés depuis sa
sortie du gouvernement italien mais le
la ligue du nord c'est beaucoup a
indiqué il ya quelques malheurs c'est
qu'ils ont changé justement le président
l'a dernièrement au mois de décembre
donc je pense que justement la ligue du
nord d'abord à changer politiquement il
venu très eurosceptique alors qu'ils
étaient plutôt européiste et que sur
toute une série de sujets ils sont en
train d'évoluer
est-ce qu'ils vont évoluer jusqu'à
pouvoir intégrer un groupe comme le
nôtre peut-être nous verrons bien
est ce que vous vous ces dernières
années et fait évoluer le front national
oui ou non marine le pen bat patty le
moment je le fait grossir par définition
quand on est aussi plus idéologique lui
de logique à 'ba2' le poème du front
national c'est que c'est un vrai parti
mais pour répondre parce que vous le
coupez
voilà donc je vais vous répondre je fais
juste une position pour respirer voilà
donc ne profitez pas pour reprendre la
parole c'est un vrai parti donc c'est un
parti qui s'attache à répondre aux
préoccupations des français ni aux
préoccupations 10
nos préoccupations il ya 20 ans est-ce
qu'ils évoluent et bien sûr ils évoluent
parce que les menaces qui pèsent sur la
france évolue mais ce que le terme c'est
de changer le nom du front national pour
vous non mais non non non non pour
l'instant ça explique pour le non ça
n'est pas ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit que
pour l'instant ça n'était pas
d'actualité mais j'ai eu du mal à
terminer ma phrase c'est peut-être pour
ça donc il était le danger il ya trente
ans c'était le socialo communisme
aujourd'hui le danger c'est l'excès de
libéralisme
par conséquent encore une fois nous
apportons des réponses à des problèmes
qui n'existent pas des problèmes qui
existent pas est ce que comme le ps ou
l'ump est ce que vous effectuerez tout
votre mandat de député européen
c'était tellement bien sûr en mai
prochain elle choisit le département là
bas je ne sais pas si ça se trouve je
serai élue présidente de la république
en 2010 est serait obligé d'interrompre
son mandat de député européen
vous ne rêvez pas pour toute la
législature européenne
en voici les français décident de me
porter à l'elysée résidentiel je pense
je pense qu nettement mes électeurs le
comprendront sur le référendum suisse
sur l'immigré sur l'immigration que vous
avez soutenu un don vous avez approuvé
le résultat est ce que de cette façon là
vous ne tirez pas aussi une balle dans
le pied des cent cinquante mille
travailleurs français transfrontalier
qui vont travailler donc chaque jour en
suisse et qui sont menacés par ce
référendum
mais je crois pas du tout je pense je
pense que l'immense majorité ne sont pas
du tout menacé par ce référendum doivent
d'abord ça c'est la première chose
et deuxièmement je pense que c'est la
responsabilité de la france de créer de
l'emploi en france est de délivrer les
salaires qui sont dignes que c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya énormément et
sans cesse enfin également qui partant
en suisse maintenant que les suisses ne
veulent pas qu au travers d'une
immigration très important qu'il y ait
une pression à la baisse sur leurs
salaires je le comprend d'autant mieux
que je dis la même chose en france à
l'égard d'autres
étrangers qui viennent travailler en
france et qui réclament des salaires qui
sont effectivement des salaires très bas
et qui du coup contribuer à peser à la
baisse sur les salaires donc voyez j'ai
une cohérence dans mon projet je défends
le droit des peuples à se défendre
lorsqu'ils sont français mais aussi
lorsqu'ils sont suisses sauf qu'ils vont
venir sans doute grossir les rangs des
chômeurs français mais ça c'est la
russie n'ont plus de boulot on ait un
sens oui mais d'accord mais enfin
écoutez être considéré qu'il faut que
les français aillent travailler ailleurs
pour pouvoir avoir un boulot excusez moi
mais moi je fais de la politique donc là
pour apporter des solutions pour que mon
pays et de l'emploi pas pour déverser
des salariés dans des pays étrangers
pour qu'ils aillent chercher le travail
que les politiques n'arrivent pas à
fabriquer en france et ceux à venir
aucun frais quel pourcentage dans quel
pourcentage de oui selon vous je pense
entre 60 et 65 % ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce référendum c'est que
les suisses ont aussi voté pour la
priorité nationale
la priorité nationale qui je m'exprime
je m'explique parce que souvent elle est
caricaturé caricaturer cette priorité
nationale qui consiste à dire que à
compétence égale un français doit
pouvoir avoir une priorité d'accès à
l'emploi par rapport à un étranger non
pas par rapport à un immigré car le
concept immigrés ne veut rien dire dans
les immigrés il ya des français
d'origine immigrée
vous avez peut-être vu aussi le cri
d'alarmé des pme suisses aujourd'hui
qu'ils disent attention c'est le retour
n'a pas prescrit la bureaucratie va
falloir qu'on remplissent des
formulaires et des familiers brenon
qu'on privilégie d'abord les salariés
suisses et pas les étrangers qui
arrivent vous avez des grosses
entreprises qui songe à se délocaliser
en irlande de quitter la suisse pour
aller en europe de l'est
ceux qui préfèrent à grammont n'y a pas
qu'en france alors que dans entreprises
ont des intérêts divergent de ceux des
peuples non mais elle gèle leurs
investissements en suisse elle des
bijoux du coup s'est félicité c'est le
tissu des pme qui sous tendent à moi je
veux bien tout ce que vous voulez mais
nous on a fait la libre circulation
totale en france et à 77 % de baisse des
investissements étrangers donc c'est pas
une question de frontières c'est juste
une question de santé économique d'un
pays et d'attractivité d'un pays je
pense que la suisse est attractive et
que personne ne partira de suisse vous
le dis très clairement de la même
manière je ne crois pas une demi-seconde
que l'union européenne va imposer comme
elle l'a menacé de le faire des
sanctions à l'égard de la scène ce mois
ci trois heures
concrètement je m'arrête je m'interroge
si si ça je peux vous sur ce mois ci
monsieur car en suisse à la différence
de la france on respecte la volonté du
peuple on considère que le peuple est
souverain et quand il dit quelque chose
personne la classe politique suisse
n'envisage de ne pas respecter ce qu'a
dit le peuple suisse
à la différence de la france où on a
violé le référendum le résultat du
référendum de 2005 est notre question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on menace la suisse de
contrepartie de sanctions en matière
sont exactement mais et avec le maroc
avec le canada l'accord de libre échange
que l'union européenne a signé la
contrepartie ça a été l'ouverture totale
des frontières la libre circulation je
ne crois pas d'où ma question parce
qu'entre robert n'a pas plutôt intérêt à
se souder fait plutôt casse ou combattre
ce dock strictement rien dire
est ce qu'ils sont de rien dire ah bon
est ce que la souveraineté à ce moment
là elle n'a pas un sens plutôt au niveau
européen qu'au niveau national
non d'ailleurs la preuve en est c'est
que ça ne marche pas la preuve en est
c'est que grenier avec wii nommé
d'accord l'union soviétique aussi on a
cherché à l'arrco régime est reparti
pour les pays de l'union européenne de
voir cette soudaine de haut niveau au
magazine madame réponse même si l'on
sent la mondiale il a dit non si on veut
je dis oui on est en train de se diluer
dans la mondialisation on est en train
d'opérer le saccage économique et
sociale à cause des règles mondialiste
qui nous sont imposées par l'union
européenne est ce que vous savez qu'il
ya eu l'année dernière 30 %
d'augmentation des travailleurs détachés
en france est ce que vous savez qu'il ya
des grands chantiers français où 40% de
ceux qui travaillent sont des étrangers
qui vont travailler dans les pays
frontaliers
ces trains c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de
nos jeunes qui fuient la france et si
vous considérez qu'il faut s'en réjouir
et bien moi je ne m'en réjouis pas loin
de là je préférerais que les jeunes
français aient envie de rester en france
parce qu'ils espèrent y trouver un
emploi ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui une petite question
d'actualité nationale pour finir entre
sarkozy et patrick buisson et
visiblement c'est fini ça vous inspire
quoi
rien matin sur europe 1 à propos
d'europe
que pensez vous de la jeunesse d'ukraine
qui se mobilisent pour justement à
adhérer aux valeurs européennes
bon comme c'est bien présent pas bah oui
oui ses 110 ans attendait comment
voulez-vous je dire deux choses je vais
vous dire il ya l'envié et la jeunesse
autour du côté de ses valeurs alors moi
je vais vous dire la vérité c'est que la
manière dont vous présentez ça est
extrêmement binaire c'est un côté
bisounours ça il ya des gros méchants
d'un côté pile est très très gentil de
nous faire réagir
le problème c'est que dans les opposants
et c'est un vrai problème dans les
opposants russes au gouvernement russe
il y à une partie craignent un pardon il
y à une partie qu'ils sont des
mouvements qu'on qualifierait où la très
largement en france donnant droit tant
donné on agite ce brain voilà d'accord
même est donc juste présenter les choses
telles qu'elles sont plutôt que de
donner une vision encore une fois la
guimauve de ce qui se passera si une
part de la route et bien sûr mais
l'ukraine est un pays lui crime tapis
historiques liant est tiraillé entre eux
son côté européen et son côté russe
c'est un vrai souci et j'espère qu'ils
arriveront à trouver par l'intermédiaire
des élections une issue démocratique à
ces problèmes car ce serait dramatique
de voir l'ukraine arraché en deux est
allé jusqu'à la partition alors une
petite question sur les européennes
on n'a pas parlé de jean marie le pen
candidat à 85 ans est ce que le monde le
mandat de trois ans à partir de quel âge
pour vous il n'y a pas de mandat du trot
il n'y a pas de mandat de trop c'est aux
électeurs de décider je crois merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la
semaine prochaine nous serons au salon
d'agriculture au public sénat d'ailleurs
va déployer pas mal d'émissions à partir
de samedi a très vite sami frey merci